Now, as we start to think about
building regression models
with this data set, we need
to consider the possibility
that there is
multicollinearity within
the independent variables.
And there's a good
reason to suspect
that there would be
multicollinearity amongst
the variables,
because in some sense,
they're all measuring
the same thing, which
is how strong the Republican
candidate is performing
in the particular state.
So while normally, we would
run the correlation function
on the training set, in
this case, it doesn't work.
It says, x must be numeric.
And if we go back and look at
the structure of the training
set, it jumps out why
we're getting this issue.
It's because we're
trying to take
the correlations of
the names of states,
which doesn't make any sense.
So to compute the
correlation, we're
going to want to take the
correlation amongst just
the independent
variables that we're
going to be using to
predict, and we can also
add in the dependent variable
to this correlation matrix.
So I'll take cor
of the training set
but just limit it to the
independent variables--
Rasmussen, SurveyUSA,
PropR, and DiffCount.
And then also, we'll add in the
dependent variable, Republican.
So there we go.
We're seeing a lot
of big values here.
For instance,
SurveyUSA and Rasmussen
are independent variables that
have a correlation of 0.94,
which is very, very
large and something
that would be concerning.
It means that probably
combining them
together isn't going to do much
to produce a working regression
model.
So let's first
consider the case where
we want to build a logistic
regression model with just one
variable.
So in this case,
it stands to reason
that the variable
we'd want to add
would be the one
that is most highly
correlated with the
outcome, Republican.
So if we read the
bottom row, which
is the correlation of each
variable to Republican,
we see that PropR is
probably the best candidate
to include in our
single-variable model,
because it's so
highly correlated,
meaning it's going to do
a good job of predicting
the Republican status.
So let's build a model.
We can call it mod1.
So we'll call the glm function,
predicting Republican,
using PropR alone.
As always, we'll
pass along the data
to train with as
our training set.
And because we have
logistic regression,
we need family = "binomial".
And we can take a look at
this model using the summary
function.
And we can see that
it looks pretty
nice in terms of
its significance
and the sign of
the coefficients.
We have a lot of
stars over here.
PropR is the
proportion of the polls
that said the Republican won.
We see that that has a very
high coefficient in terms
of predicting that the
Republican will win
in the state, which
makes a lot of sense.
And we'll note down
that the AIC measuring
the strength of
the model is 19.8.
So this seems like a
very reasonable model.
Let's see how it does in
terms of actually predicting
the Republican outcome
on the training set.
So first, we want to
compute the predictions,
the predicted probabilities
that the Republican
is going to win on
the training set.
So we'll create a vector
called pred1, prediction one,
then we'll call the
predict function.
We'll pass it our model one.
And we're not going
to pass it newdata,
because we're just
making predictions
on the training set right now.
We're not looking at
test set predictions.
But we do need to pass it type =
"response" to get probabilities
out as the predictions.
And now, we want to see
how well it's doing.
So if we used a
threshold of 0.5,
where we said if the
probability is at least 1/2,
we're going to
predict Republican,
otherwise, we'll
predict Democrat.
Let's see how that would
do on the training set.
So we'll want to use
the table function
and look at the training
set Republican value
against the logical
of whether pred1
is greater than or equal to 0.5.
So here, the rows, as usual, are
the outcome -- 1 is Republican,
0 is Democrat.
And the columns-- TRUE
means that we predicted
Republican, FALSE means
we predicted Democrat.
So we see that on
the training set,
this model with one
variable as a prediction
makes four mistakes,
which is just
about the same as our
smart baseline model.
So now, let's see if we can
improve on this performance
by adding in another variable.
So if we go back up to
our correlations here,
we're going to be
searching, since there's
so much multicollinearity,
we might be searching
for a pair of variables that has
a relatively lower correlation
with each other, because they
might kind of work together
to improve the
prediction overall
of the Republican outcome.
If two variables are
highly, highly correlated,
they're less likely to
improve predictions together,
since they're so similar in
their correlation structure.
So it looks like, just looking
at this top left four by four
matrix, which is the
correlations between all
the independent variables,
basically the least correlated
pairs of variables are either
Rasmussen and DiffCount,
or SurveyUSA and DiffCount.
So the idea would
be to try out one
of these pairs in our
two-variable model.
So we'll go ahead and try
out SurveyUSA and DiffCount
together in our second model.
So to save ourselves
some typing,
we can hit up a
few times until we
get to the model
definition for model one.
And then we can just
change the variables.
In this case, we're now using
SurveyUSA plus DiffCount.
We'll also need to remember to
change the name of our model
from mod1 to mod2.
And now, just like
before, we're going
to want to compute
out our predictions.
So we'll say pred2 is equal
to the predict of our model 2,
again, with type =
"response", because we
need to get those probabilities.
Again, we're not
passing in newdata.
This is a training
set prediction.
And finally, we can
use the up arrows
to see how our second
model's predictions are doing
at predicting the Republican
outcome in the training set.
And we can see that we
made one less mistake.
We made three mistakes instead
of four on the training
set-- so a little better
than the smart baseline
but nothing too impressive.
And the last thing we're
going to want to do
is to actually look at the
model and see if it makes sense.
So we can run summary
of our model two.
And we can see that there are
some things that are pluses.
For instance, the AIC
has a smaller value,
which suggests a stronger model.
And the estimates have, again,
the sign we would expect.
So SurveyUSA and DiffCount
both have positive coefficients
in predicting if
the Republican wins
the state, which makes sense.
But a weakness of this model is
that neither of these variables
has a significance
of a star or better,
which means that they are less
significant statistically.
So there are definitely some
strengths and weaknesses
between the two-variable
and the one-variable model.
We'll go ahead and use
the two-variable model
when we make our predictions
on the testing set.